you can't really deny the success of the
switch and Nintendo has a bold
prediction about its latest console I'm
Tony and this is your best-selling
GameSpot news update as part of
Nintendo's latest earnings report the
company updated its sales forecasts for
the switch if all goes as expected the
switch will sell more units in its first
year on the market than the Wii U sold
in its entire run as of the end of
September the switch has sold seven
point six three million units worldwide
prompting Nintendo to predict a total of
14 million sold by the end of this
fiscal year that calendar runs from
April 2017 to March 2018 which means it
doesn't even include launch units sold
this March as for the Wii U that system
has only sold about 13 and a half
million since its launch in 2012 that's
a lot of numbers but they all spell
success for Nintendo in fact company
president Tatsumi Kim Mishima has stated
it's still boosting production to meet
the demand as for games on the new
console Super Mario Odyssey is also a
hit earning itself a coveted ten out of
ten from GameSpot and you can always
check out that video review for more
info
[Music]